so
i've made multiple videos about this
already ml news reported apple is
releasing their new system to detect
child abuse material which includes
running code on the device of the actual
users before they upload images to
icloud i've also made a video about the
technical summary that apple released
where they detail how they're going to
preserve user privacy in the face of all
of this and the system is pretty smart
but in that video i already pointed out
while the cryptographic and security
part of the system is smart and fulfills
all the privacy requirements of what
apple claims the neural network part is
the weak part right here but also in
that video i outlined two weak points of
the system the first weak point is who
controls the database who does the
manual checking and so on this is
politics i guess the second part is the
neural network part at the beginning of
this whole pipeline there is a neural
network that is trained to recognize
when two images are the same so the
neural network is supposed to be robust
to some transformations for example if
you resize the image if you re-encode
the image and so on the bits of the
image will change however the neural
network should still recognize that that
is the same image and you can definitely
train neural networks to do that however
criticism has come up and i've mentioned
this as well that neural networks being
neural networks they can be tampered
with with so-called adversarial attacks
now it didn't even take a week before
code was released to find the model that
apple is using on device it was actually
on my computer the whole time and
convert that to a format that we can
work with in neural network frameworks
also we already have the first reports
of a forced collision that means two
images that look essentially nothing
alike yet the network thinks that is the
same image so this can be potentially
used to frame someone i.e send them
images that are seemingly innocuous yet
the images are perturbed in just the
right way to make apple think they're
the same as one of the images in their
database on the other hand using the
same techniques called adversarial
attacks we can also evade this system
meaning that we can change this neural
hash of any image pretty much as we
please so i thought hey why not give it
a try so this is partially based on code
that's already available and i'll link
to that i'll make my code available that
has references to that code that i'm
basing my work on so i'm gonna show you
how to force a collision if you
understand how to force a collision it's
pretty easy to also understand how you
can evade a collision so that exercise
is left to the reader
forcing a collision is actually the more
difficult part so that's what i'm going
to show you today and this is doable by
anyone with introductory skills to deep
learning programming all right so first
we're gonna need uh some sort of a image
that we want to perturb let's take this
image right here of uh nice doggy hey
shiba inu and let's assume that we are
in possession of an image that we know
is in the database of bad material
pretend for a second that this image of
the titanic is that image that is in the
database all right so i've already used
the code available online to convert the
model into the onnx format which is an
interchangeable format for the different
frameworks of deep learning and then i
further converted it to a tensorflow
format which is one of the major
frameworks for deep learning now with a
little bit of plumbing i can then
further shove this into a library called
the adversarial robustness toolbox which
is used to do research on adversarial
examples so our plan is going to be
essentially we have the source image and
if we just run that through the neural
pipeline it will give us some neural
hash at the end that neural hash is
computed from the network's output which
is some vector in high dimensional space
if we run the target image through the
same neural network we'll get a
different vector and because of that
we'll get a different neural hash now
what we can do with an adversarial
attack is we can compute the minimal
perturbation necessary to the source
image and that's really going to be a
tiny perturbation you can't see it with
a naked eye but this tiny perturbation
if we do it in the right way causes the
output to change all the way to align
with the output vector of the target
image and if we align the two vectors
closely enough then they will output the
same neural hash they will fall into the
same bucket of the lsh algorithm and
they will give the same output i've
explained in the last video already what
lsh is and how that works so if you want
to find more about that check it out so
when i recorded this i was a bit over
eager in what i could do though i'm
pretty sure with some engineering this
can be smoothed out but you see the
image on the left is the one we started
with and our target image is this image
of the titanic and the image on the
bottom is the collision image so it's
noticeably different so first of all the
resizing that's just the fact of the
algorithm that doesn't matter actually
but you can clearly see there are some
artifacts in the image however you would
still notice it as being very similar to
the original image yet it is in the same
bucket so it has the same neural hash as
the titanic image which you know that's
pretty astonishing alright so as you can
see the code for this is relatively
minimal and we don't have to run this
for long until we actually find a
collision and the image that we craft
looks like this remember this has the
same neural hash as the titanic image so
on apple's side at least before the
manual review this shows up as being
flagged to be the same as this titanic
image it should be plainly obvious you
know how you can frame people if you see
these things now if you get this crafted
image you don't think twice that this
could be some kind of mal intended
essentially a virus and as soon as you
upload it to icloud in apple's
headquarters the red light flashes next
to your name now hold on you might say
in order to pull off this attack you do
actually need this
titanic-ish image right therefore you
must already be in pretty shady waters
because the possession of this image
presumably is illegal already and i'm
here to tell you not necessarily see
since uh we now have another image that
you know is not an illegal image it's
not the same image to a human but
nevertheless that image is in fact in
this bucket we now are in possession of
a completely legal image from the
illegal bucket so in the future we can
simply use that image as the target
image so technically only one person at
the very beginning has to have access to
some kind of illegal material and they
can simply pass on the non-robust
features that we all adjust to and
subsequently nobody is doing anything
illegal yet we're able to essentially
ddos apple with this there you go we've
just beaten the most valuable company on
the planet with ironically a laptop that
they manufactured in less than a few
minutes now what does it matter you ask
well i think this is pretty worrisome so
there's a system that's implemented on
all of these devices it essentially
normalizes companies running code on
your devices and given that they have
exclusive control over these databases
and given that we see everyday
governments going to these companies
right now it's in different countries
but surely can happen everywhere on the
world i don't think this is necessarily
a good thing given the trade-off we're
doing here this is so easy to evade and
this is so easy to abuse at the end it
seems like there must be better methods
of achieving our goals here alright that
was it check out code subscribe check
out next ml news
[Music]
you